>> I am very happy to
introduce Fredrik Johansson,
who is coming to us from MIT
working with [inaudible].
He has been doing a lot of
variance works at forefront of
the machine learning and
causal inference and
I'm very much looking
forward to hearing the talk.
>> Thank you so much.
Great to be here.
Yeah, so for the last couple of
years I've been thinking a lot about
causal effects and
the biggest reason for that is
that I'm working in something
called a clinical machine learning
group at MIT and almost all of
the problems that we work with,
with some exceptions, are inspired
in some way by health care.
So, I'll go through a few examples
of what that might mean.
One of the very first problems
that David worked on in
his lab was predicting
diabetes onset and as
you know that diabetes
is a very large problem
here in the United States
in particular but others as
well and this is your standard
prediction problem.
You want to figure out
what is the risk of
a person developing
type two diabetes.
So, what they did in this work,
I wasn't part of this but
essentially look at
the personal health record
or insurance record and
find features that are predictive
of the risk of developing
type two diabetes.
So, the question here is
essentially, who is at risk?
Who should we think about perhaps
intervening on or
treating differently?
A more recent problem that
I'm thinking about is
opioid addiction which is very
relevant on the East Coast.
I don't know anything about opioid
addiction on the West Coast,
but it's a very big problem
in the States as well
and essentially what we
want to figure out here is,
what about the health care system
or what about the way that we're
prescribing opioids now is
driving addiction essentially.
Over 10,000 people every year die
from overdoses related
to prescription opioids.
So, these are not
drugs from the street,
they are potentially overdoses
that we could prevent
and people need pain medication
but in a lot of cases we
could prescribe less.
So, we know simple things like
larger prescriptions mean
high risk of developing addiction
that's very reasonable but
perhaps we can figure out
other reasons for or
other drivers of this.
Lastly, I'll mention
sepsis management
which is something that a lot of
people in machine learning
community and I've looked at when
it comes to health care tasks.
Sepsis is one of the leading
causes of death in
the intensive care unit and it's
a complication of an infection.
So, essentially you can have really
horrible complications such as
organ failure et cetera
and one of the first things
you should do obviously
when it comes to
infection is to treat the infection.
But a lot of the things that we
do when we treat patients with
sepsis is also just management.
Things like the
blood pressure, the artery,
the oxygen intake can all be
affected by this and this
is the more continuous task
of managing patients.
We have to make sure that all these
things are in the right range.
So, for example, if
your oxygen drops too low you,
might want to put the patient
on a mechanical ventilator
and if you do that you might want
to sedate the patient et cetera.
So, this is more of a sequential
process and we want
to manage these patients so that
their long-term quality of life is
good as opposed to just
making them survive
the first 24 or 48 hours or whatever
they spend in the ICU because
a lot of the interventions that
we do have long-term effects.
So, these three problems illustrate
essentially three different modes
of applying machine
learning in health care
and the first one being
a very standard
prediction problem that
I'm sure most of you have worked with
a lot and essentially
figuring out who's at risk of
diabetes onset is something
that we can do using
just supervised learning
or prediction methods.
But the second one,
figuring out what are
the drivers of opioid
medication and how can
we prescribe opioids differently
so that we reduce the risk
of developing addiction,
that's more of the causal problems
that I will be focusing on today.
Essentially, we might be
able to or we might consider
choosing between a synthetic
and unnatural opioid,
I should say medication,
and we're interested in
what is the contrast
between the responses under
these two choices of medication.
The last one is more of
a sequential decision-making problem
or reinforcement learning problem
if we want to treat it like
that but we make a series
of choices where
each choice depends on
the previous choices but also what
happened as a result of them.
We can think of this as a slightly
more complicated version of
this in other cases but
we're also interested in
slightly different quantity.
We want to figure out
what's a good policy,
a good reactive policy for it.
If we see a patient
in a certain state,
what should we do which is slightly
different from this where
in which we might consider.
If I choose between these two things
for everyone in the population,
what would happen.
Whereas in the policy
setting we might not
consider the whole range
of actions for everyone.
So, the broad theme of
this talk will be to predict
effects of decisions and
we need somehow
causal reasoning to do this.
This is what I argue on,
I'm sure you've heard this argument
before from others here and
the main thing that I've
been thinking a lot about
recently is that we have a lot
of high dimensional data in
health care and it's not only
because of the sequential problem,
but also the fact that we
have diagnosis information,
we have other kinds of
medical history and we
have a bunch of symptoms,
we have genetic information,
in some cases we have X-rays,
a lot of the things
that contribute to
a high-dimensional data regime.
Then the second part of this talk
will be essentially linking this
to domain adaptation which
is something that I've
done successfully in the past.
Domain adaptation,
if you know, is part
of transfer learning
or an instance of
transfer learning and it
has a lot of similarities with
causal effect estimation.
So, the last part is
an open question but
recently I was working on
a product of essentially
trying to figure out what would go
wrong if we apply something like
reinforcement learning
without thinking too much
in healthcare problem
and specifically,
I will be talking causally
about what's called off policy
or observational settings where
we can't run an experiment
is essentially.
So, in those settings what should
we try to figure out about
our policies before we
apply them in practice.
So, the types of problems
that we think most about in
our group is something like
this or at least I do.
There's a lot of work on
sequential things as well.
We'll get there a bit later.
So, we can imagine a patient
coming into the hospital,
she's 54 years old and female
and she has high blood sugar.
So, this could be
a pre-diabetic patient.
We have to figure out
how can we manage
her blood sugars so that it's lower
a few months down the line and we can
consider choosing between
two different medications to do so.
The question then is
a few months down the line,
which of these medications will have
a better effect on her blood sugar
and these will be what
we call the potential
outcomes of this choice.
So, I will denote here by
Y0 the outcome that we
observe if we were to give
medication A and Y1 the opposite
of the outcome under medication B.
So, in a lot of cases we
could perform an experiment
to try and figure this out.
We can gather a bunch of
pre-diabetic patients and then test
these two medications
separately and figure
out what was the average response
or even conditional response
in these groups.
But for a lot of cases we can't
do that and it could be because
the patients are hard to
recruit or might be expensive,
but there are also some types
of interventions that we just
can't randomize like forcing
patients to smoke to see the
effect of that et cetera.
So, the typical dataset we
will be thinking about
is something like this.
We have some descriptors about
the patients like their age
and blood pressure et cetera,
and we have essentially
a column recording
which treatment they
received previously.
We know what their blood sugar
was a few months down the line.
We want to figure out what
among these choices of
treatment was the better one.
The problem of course
is that we can only
observe the outcome under
one of these treatments.
So, what we would like
is essentially to fill
in these missing cells in
this table and crucially
these cells are not
missing at random. Yeah.
>> Do we also the
pre-treatment of blood sugar?
>> Yeah. That can be. Exactly.
>> [inaudible]
>> Oh, sorry. The question was,
do we also know the blood sugar
prior to treatment and yeah
that would be a good feature
to collect for sure.
Yeah, so essentially this slide
is meant to illustrate that
these cells that we want
to fill in we can't treat
them as the standard
prediction problem
in the sense that they're
not missing at random.
The observations that we have
are not representative
of the observations
that we want necessarily.
So that will be the goal of
this talk to figure them out.
So, I will introduce some notation
to talk about these things
and the first being X big feature.
Feature vector essentially or
covariate representation,
this could be an image,
this could be some insurance
claim information.
We have treatment assignments T,
which for the majority of
the talk I will assume is
binary and choice of A or B.
We have potential outcomes under
these two different treatments.
This will be Y(0) and Y(1)
and our goal is to figure out
the outcome under an intervention
for specific patient X,
where a patient represented
by feature X or
the difference between
two interventions
or the outcomes under
each two interventions.
I think that's easier
if I just show what I
mean in terms or using a figure.
This here could be the outcome
under the first intervention,
the control outcome
if you would like.
A function of X, for example,
age and I've put mortality
on the x-axis here.
It's likely that you are more at
risk of death when you're older.
The question is can we use
a treatment to sort of reduce
this risk of mortality?
That might be the case, we can have
a function that represents
the outcome under treatment
that looks something like this.
These are just invented, but this
is not unreasonable to assume.
If you're at high enough edge,
there's nothing we can do,
but perhaps in the sort
of middle region here
the treatment has an effect.
What you can see is essentially
a couple of things,
the effect of choosing the treatment.
Treatment one over
treatment zero seems to
have an effect in some
regions but not in all.
So we have what's called a
heterogeneous treatment effect.
But also it seems to be mostly
sort of beneficial, the treatment,
like this difference between
these two lines which
is what we're interested
in is mostly negative.
So you reduce the mortality
if you choose treatment one.
We don't observe these lines.
These curves are the goal
with this study or those are
where we want to find out,
but we observe only a skewed
sample of these curves.
It's illustrated with a table before.
We might have a situation
something like this,
where we have a treated group.
This should be zero and one,
and that, one and zero by the way.
A treated group that's
a little skewed to
the older population
here that you're more
likely to receive
treatment if you're older,
and a control group which is
younger, and even worse than this,
we don't observe the curves in
the support of these
densities either we observe
samples from these densities.
Essentially, we might
see something like this,
where we have a bunch of
younger patients that
didn't receive treatment.
These are the blue dots here
following the solid curve,
and we have a bunch
of treated patients that
are a little bit older.
If you look now at
the average response
to treatment or the average outcome
in these two different groups,
we see essentially that the average
for the treated population is
higher and the average for
the control population slower.
What we concluded before was that
the treatment was always beneficial.
So it's kind of surprising
or not if you've seen
an example like this before,
but it's where you can
see is essentially that these
average do not tell the story that
we're interested in because here
it appears that the effect Tau or
the difference between
these two outcomes
is adverse on average as
opposed to beneficial.
This is an instance of compounding.
This age here influences not
only the response to treatment
but also the treatment itself.
We have a few problems
essentially as far as I'm
concerned, we have compounding,
which is what I've just
illustrated that if we
look at the just the sample
averages that we receive,
we get the wrong idea of the effect.
We also have an overlap problem which
I didn't talk too
much about it before,
but you can see that these two
groups are essentially disjoint,
and we have to work
with that somehow.
The typical way to
solve these problems
in causal inference at least papers,
I hope not in practice,
is to assume that these do not
exist, these two problems.
We will talk a lot about this
going forward, but essentially,
that the first assumption that people
tend to make in
these kind of situations
is something called ignorability,
in which you assume
that if you know X,
if have enough variables
to predict essentially the
treatment assignment well,
the two potential outcomes that you
are interested in should be
independent of that treatment.
So if you control for X, we
can estimate the effect Tau.
The other one is common support,
saying essentially that,
at any point along the
axis that I showed before,
at any point in the covariate space,
we have some probability of
receiving any of the treatments.
So if we want to compare
the difference between
two treatments or the outcomes
on the two treatments,
we would need of course to
have samples from each,
and this is what I'll talk
most about I think today.
There are more assumptions
that you need,
like IID assumptions is one of them.
This consistency is another,
it is saying essentially that
if you prescribe treatment T,
you will observe the outcome
under that treatment,
and this is not always true.
If a patient elects not to take
the treatment prescribed then
you're not going to see
that outcome clearly.
I will take this for granted
for now and I will talk
about the other ones.
We still have observed compounding,
we still have our variables X
that we need to control for.
Roughly speaking, what we would
like is to figure out what
is the observed outcome under
treatment for patient X,
but we only have
this function for the people who
over this receive that treatment.
We only see the outcome under
treatment for the treated.
So how do we connect these two?
Well, there are a couple of
different solutions to that.
Essentially, if you have the two
conditions that I showed before,
there are suite of methods
that you can apply
to cross this, sort of divide.
Three of the most
classical ones are these.
Regression, essentially
fits a function to
each potential outcome or
each observed outcome under
each treatment, and re-weighting.
I'm sure you've seen before in
other contexts if you
haven't done this,
essentially doing
important sampling to figure out
how do we find a
representative sample
of the whole population from
the biased sample that we have,
matching just pairing up
essentially people with
similar covariates to
figure out what would be
their counterfactual outcome if
they had the opposite treatment.
I will talk mostly about
regression estimators today,
and under the two assumptions
that we had before,
we only have to do regression
to solve our problem with
some caveats in the sense
that we might not
have the amount of
samples that we need,
but essentially, under
those conditions you get that
the potential outcome
under a certain treatment
is equal to the conditional outcome.
You can do this in a lot
of different ways,
you can solve these kinds of
regression problems in
a lot of different ways.
The most simple one or the most
perhaps intuitive for
someone who comes from
a machine learning background
is to treat these two curves as
two different prediction problems
to solve or to two different
estimation problems.
You can try and fit the blue curve
separately and the orange curve
separately and take
their or construct
their difference to
get your prediction,
but there are also methods
specifically designed to estimate
the difference at once and not
solve the two prediction problems.
Our problem remains that
if our two treatment groups
are very different,
for example, if we
didn't have overlap,
solving these estimation
problems is not going be
easy at least in
the sense that the error
that we have on the data
that we observed is not
going to be representative
of the error
that we expect on a
different or counterfactual
intervention if you like,
where we assign
the opposite treatment.
There are a few different problems
that make this hard,
and the most relevant to this talk
is that we have
often high-dimensional data.
There are essentially
two aspects of this
that have basically
the opposite calculations.
One is this idea that if
we measure more variables,
we're less likely to have
left out something that we
need to adjust for compounding.
This is true, but I put an asterisk
here in the sense that we're
not guaranteed to have less bias
necessarily if we
include more variables.
This is a little technical,
but you can show essentially that If
you include variables
that you shouldn't have,
you will introduce more bias
than if you left them out.
The most famous example of
that I think is M-bias,
which is I'm not going to get
into what that is exactly,
but another one would be where
you condition on a variable that
happened as a result of treatment or
after treatment as opposed before,
so you can introduce selection
bias and that kind of thing.
But this I am sure you're much more
aware of all the time
because whenever we have
high dimensionality,
we have to struggle
with sample sizes.
In this case, we also
have a different kind
of curse of high dimensionality
in the sense that,
it's less likely there
are two treatment groups
overlap as we call it when
we have more variables.
So if you think about the matching
problem that I flashed before,
if you want to find someone who's
very similar to you with
had the opposite treatment,
that gets less and less
likely the more variables you
have, or said differently,
you could say that everyone
becomes roughly equally
comparable when you
have a lot of data or a lot
of dimensions I should
say, which is not what we want.
So, the question then is,
how do we mitigate this curse
of dimensionality?
Specifically, what I've
been thinking about is,
can we learn a
representation or can we
find a representation
of our data fee?
Such that we still have
the two assumptions that
we needed for estimating
causal effects,
we still need ignorability,
we needed to address for
compounding and we also need
a common support of course,
but if we find a
representation that's
smaller than the original space,
there's a chance that we can sort of
bump up the margins
on this a little bit.
We can find a better support
or better overlap than
what we had before.
So, if you think of this as being
a large number of covariates,
for example, that we
want to adjust for,
just removing some of
the variables would be
the easiest way to achieve this.
We have a better chance
of having overlap.
So, I've thought about
this problem for a while.
A few years ago,
I started working on this and what
we did essentially at
that point was to starting,
draw comparisons between
causal effect estimation
and domain adaptation. Go ahead.
>> Is there, I
don't know like then quickly
illustrate an example to
see if our fee affects
might have the ignorability
like in your mortality example
like we'll see that okay,
maybe we'll start
discretizing it or I think
then we'll obviously
get with their overlap.
>> So the question was,
is there an example
that illustrates how fee can
be useful for
ignorability or helpful?
It's the opposite.
Whenever we remove information
that it's less likely that this will
hold except for the biases
that I mentioned before.
But yeah, so that is
actually the problem.
We want to find fee to achieve this,
but this is the constraint
that we have essentially.
>> So let me
think about not having [inaudible]
things that are maybe really biased,
then would I effectively be
asking what is the largest,
extra smallest satisfying
notability already?
I'm just asking what is
the largest fee I can work with
getting [inaudible] or good enough?
>> Yeah. So the question
again for the,
sorry for the recording is,
oh man. Sorry, I wish
I could [inaudible].
Yes.
Essentially, should I try and get
the largest fees so that I
have common support or better,
let's say, better chance
of getting common support?
But so that I still believe
that I have ignorability.
Yeah. I think that's
a reasonable way to think about it.
This will be a trade off for sure.
Essentially, you can
think of this as variance
and this as bias, right?
In some cases, you
might have an easier time
achieving this than you might,
that you might be more
concerned about keeping
information that are moving in.
I don't have a great general
answer to that question,
but I think that's
a reasonable approach to take.
Maybe after we see some algorithm or
theory that you might have
a better idea of that,
I hope that's the case.
So, we started thinking
about domain adaptation
because turns out is
very similar to what I'm
talking about and I
used to just say what I learned
from domain adaptation here,
but essentially, I've
changed my mind a lot on on
the topic of domain adaptation
to working with this problem.
So, we will consider just one side of
the causal effect
estimation problem from
before and essentially we will
try and predict this blue curve,
there's outcome under
control medication
for the treated population.
So for the red points,
we want to infer
what is their sort of
location on the blue.
Doing this one-sided
problem or solving
that one-sided problem
turns out to be the same as
doing what's called
unsupervised domain adaptation,
and in that specific formulation.
So domain adaptation is essentially
the idea that you want to
learn a model or fit a model on
one type of data and then
apply it to something else,
or one distribution of data
and apply it somewhere else.
The data that you have essentially in
the specifically unsupervised
domain adaptation formulation
is labels from what's called
a source domain and features from
that domain and then I have
only features from another domain
called the target domain.
So you have features and labels from
the source and only
features from the target.
So, these map do
counter-factual
prediction in the sense
that these are your
factual control outcomes,
the outcomes that you observe,
and you have your treated group,
but not treated labels essentially
based on the slide that I
showed a minute ago and
your goal is to figure
out the labels for
the unlabeled group.
The assumptions are very
similar in these two problems,
the counterfactual
prediction and demand
adaptation in the sense that we
have this ignorability condition
still that I showed before,
but it would be called something like
covariate shift in domain adaptation.
It's usually written
slightly differently,
but the idea is essentially that
the labeling function that we
want to learn and apply in
a different context doesn't
change between domains.
So, p of y given x.
If you like, it's fixed when you
go from one domain to the next.
One of the most often considered
tasks in domain adaptation,
at least when it comes to
the machine learning community,
is image classification essentially.
This is a benchmark that people
are very comfortable with
and these illustrate
two different benchmark problems
that are often used.
Here on the top row,
we see, well, I don't
know if you can see it,
but it's digits from house numbers
that have been cropped.
So, essentially, the center digit
is the label of the image.
So seven, three, and zero, I think,
and the bottom row here is MNIST
that you've seen a million times.
But what's happening here
is essentially that we use
these images for learning and we want
to predict the labels of
these images in the bottom.
A domain adaptation algorithm,
suite of domain adaptation algorithm
is achieved at
an accuracy on MNIST of
about 80 percent or so having
learned only from these SVHN digits.
The random guess would be a lot
worse than that, 10 percent or so.
So, something seems
to be working here.
But what you can also see is
that these two densities or
these two classes of digits or
images do not overlap at all.
There's measured zero for
the house numbers in this set.
So, how does that work?
We're extrapolating
essentially wildly.
We were extrapolating to
somewhere we don't have any data.
In this example, you can see
perhaps a bit better
why this might work in
the sense that these are
synthetic street signs
and these are real ones,
and I mean, they can
looks similar, right?
I mean, they have done a decent job
synthesizing street signs,
but still we don't have overlap
in the strict sense of the word.
So, okay.
If we want to connect
domain adaptation
to causal effect estimation,
when can we expect
a similar performance for
estimating causal effects?
When can we expect to do that even
though we don't have overlap?
>> I have a question.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I guess,
when you showed here
corresponding quantities in
domain adaptation for instance,
one thing that was maybe interesting
for me was hypothesis class.
>> Yeah. I will get to that, yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Exactly. So, I'll take
the machine learning view of things
now and think about
risk minimization.
So, I won't assume that
I have the right model.
Yeah. I didn't repeat
that question by the way.
He was asking me if I think
about the hypothesis class
essentially when it comes to
causal effect estimation, and yes.
>> For the common overlap, should I
be thinking of
the problem of this has
been estimated or
this is [inaudible].
>> Sorry, you repeat
the first part of it.
>> For the common overlap assumption.
>> Yeah.
>> Is this a statement that
we are making about the data
generating distribution or is
it we are like estimating that
we'd like to stay [inaudible]
>> So, the question is for
the overlap condition.
Should I think about those
as being estimated densities
or the data generating process?
For now, we can think about
this data generating process.
But whenever we do
something that relies on
knowing them obviously,
we will have to estimate
them in practice typically.
I will not assume that we know
say a policy for treatment.
>> I think I'm just
getting tripped up when
I'm learning the representations fee.
How am I assuming
that interfaces with
this data-generating
process that may have
no knowledge of
what fee I come across.
>> Yes. So, okay.
So, the question is,
if the fee is invented by
the practitioner or whatever,
how can I connect that to the
assumptions that I'm
making about the data?
We will see why that
can be a problem later.
So, the risk that we would like to
minimize now for the purposes
of this part of the talk is,
essentially the risk in
predicting the control outcomes.
So, that's F0 would be our
hypothesis for the control outcome.
For the treated group
so I have a one here.
So, R1 F0 is the risk for
the control outcome for the treated.
Essentially, this is
just what you expect,
the expected loss under
the assignment for
the treatment group
and the loss can be something
like the square loss,
so the 0-1 loss, etc.
If you do have overlap,
a way to get a
consistent estimator of
this quantity would be to
use important weights.
Where you take your empirical risk
and essentially just re-weight
each sample by the ratio of
its likelihood under the
treated and the control groups.
But as we don't have overlap,
we can't do this because P0
might be zero somewhere.
So, we don't expect to have
good overlap in high dimensions.
Even if we did in some extreme sense
or in some theoretical sense,
this estimator will have
a very high variance.
So, we're not going to do
importance weighting here.
So, what we can do is to take
some inspiration then from
domain adaptation and we
can try and bound the risk
instead of trying to estimate
it using importance weighting.
So, we're not necessarily
going to have
a consistent estimator
in the classical sense,
but at least we can figure out
maybe something about
how poorly we're doing.
Or get at least direction
to in which to optimize.
So, if we have ignored ability
with respect to the variables x,
we can write a bound
in the following way,
where we say that
the counterfactual risk or
the risk that we defined
on the previous slide,
is bounded by the factual risks.
So, this is how poorly
are we fitting the curve,
the blue curve for the blue points.
This here measures
essentially how different
can do extrapolations be
in your hypothesis plus
h to the treated group.
So, it's defined here
and this is an integral
probability metric on IPM.
There are other formulations
of this as well.
The one bound due to [inaudible].
Looks at something
called the h Delta.
H distance or in the H distance.
There are a few different
formulations of this,
but they have a very similar shape.
Essentially, you're looking at
how large can
the difference be between
the expectation of some function
evaluated over p and the value of q.
So, this is now saying,
as long as the loss function,
the loss at a point x
lives in the space h,
this bound is correct.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah.
>> It seem that from
provisional [inaudible].
>> So, actually yeah. So, I'm
glossing over some details here.
But the condition that's necessary
is that the loss of f
for any f isn't here,
isn't h. So, there's
another formulation where you get
an additional term due to
triangle inequality essentially.
Where you have the realizability
of the label in your nh.
So, people wrote down a lot of
these types of bounce
over the last 10 years.
What came out of that was essentially
a suite of algorithms that attempt to
learn a space where
this is made small,
but we can still do good prediction.
So, the goal was to minimize
an objective such as this,
essentially what I showed
you on the previous slide,
but now I've inserted a
representation of our data fee.
So, this is what we had from before.
So, think about it in terms of,
you have some original space x1,
x2 where the blue and the orange
are somehow separate.
But now, we've moved to
a new space fee where there are
more identically distributed.
But we also want to make sure that we
can fit the data that we observe.
So, this was successful
in the main adaptation and it was
used in the example that
I showed you before.
This objective where
algorithm has been used
to get those numbers
on the benchmarks.
But what we did was to
essentially apply this to few causal
effect estimation as well.
So, instead of having
a single outcome,
we now how to outcomes right.
We have an outcome for the control
and outcome for the treated.
But we share a representation
for these two predictions.
So, essentially what we do is we take
our covariates we learn
a representation and
then depending on which treatment
we did observe for every sample,
we compute the loss in fitting
that outcome either from
the control of the tree.
So, if you're in the control group,
you got to loss from
the control hypothesis, etc.
What I am not showing
on this slide here is,
essentially this type
of penalty that would
be for the shared
representation as well.
So, this is now fitting
the factual data,
but also penalizing differences
between densities in the
representation space.
So, it worked for demand application,
it turns out it works okay for
causal effect estimation as well.
This is a benchmark that's
called the IHDP dataset,
where your goal is to predict
the learning outcomes for
children based on facts about
them and their mothers.
It has been synthesized,
so the covariates are from
a real-world dataset,
but the outcome is
completely synthetic.
We compare it to a suite
of different methods,
but I don't know if you want
to go too far into this table.
These are methods based on
various versions of the new
unlikely that I showed you before.
But somewhat disappointingly
the biggest gain that
we saw from our work was essentially
the choice of architecture.
So, doing regression well seems
to do pretty well on this task.
This has been pushed forward
like this number here is 0.67
where it doing the image mapping
of optimizing to the test data
so at some point I think.
I don't think you should read
too much into these numbers,
but essentially what I
showed you in very early on,
if you have ignore ability
and if you have overlap,
doing regression well
is all you need to do.
So, I think that's
what's going on here.
We see some gain.
This is using not
the density difference penalty not
the DH term that I showed you before,
but these three are.
So, we see some gains,
but it's pretty minimal.
Essentially, adding
some regularization. Yes.
>> Describe how high
dimensional desire to be.
>> Oh, it's tiny, it's like
17 covariates or
something or 25 million.
So, that can be one reason.
But I think, yeah.
So, if you take the amines examples
from before is the same,
the domain adaptation atoms are
the same family of algorithms.
But again, evanescence is also tiny.
People have applied it to
bigger image classification task,
but the causal effect
estimation benchmarks
are typically pretty small dimension.
Yes.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yes.
>> [inaudible]. If those variables,
are you also [inaudible].
>> No. I think I will
answer that too.
So, the question is,
do I assume anything
about the homogeneity of
the treatment effect?
Because I'm getting rid of
information that could
predict treatment,
we got to make sure that that's not
predictive of the
outcome because then
we lose the ignorability assumption.
I'll show that now, I hope.
So, it seem nice empirically,
but where we have the luxury of
a hindsight for this task
and when it comes to
the domain adaptation problems,
we typically have the target labels
and we can just see how well we did.
But people have also chosen
those tasks carefully.
It's very easy to break them.
The reason that it's
easy to break them
is this can obviously go wrong.
I said that this was a bound,
but it's not necessarily
a bound for all fee.
We had this assumption that
the loss function or the loss of
your hypothesis has to live in
this family age but the
smaller you make fee,
the less likely it is that it's true.
Similarly, when I mentioned
the triangle inequality
version of this
where you have the realizability of
the label in your hypothesis class,
that also becomes much less likely,
right, if you remove
a lot of information.
So, ignorability need not
hold for the representation.
We alluded to this a long time ago.
But not only that,
we may lose information in
a sort of asymmetric way.
If it's always true that
the information that we remove is
as useful for the
factual as it is for
the counterfactual or for the
treated as for the control,
then this term will go up
the same way as this, right?
So, we have a shot that
this bound still holds even
though the assumption of the loss
being that is satisfied.
Yes, exactly, satisfied.
But this can obviously go wrong
and I don't know if we'll have
time to go through this in detail,
but you can write a very tiny example
for when it is impossible to solve
the task in the way
that we've solved it,
or where as impossible to solve
with any algorithm in fact.
So, these are essentially
your two domains,
the gray and the white.
So, these would be your source and
your target domain and
the circles and crosses
illustrate the labels.
Everything I want to show
is essentially that if you
pick either x1 or x2 as
your representation,
you will have a minimum
density difference
because the gray and the whites
are sort of symmetric.
You will have gray and white equally
regardless of the variable you pick.
But only in one case can you
perfectly separate
the circles from the crosses.
If I pick x1 as my representation,
I will not be able to do that.
So, the thing is, of course,
that there's no way for me to
tell which of this is true
because I don't observe
the labels on the target.
So, if the gray here is the target,
it doesn't matter which
I pick of x1 or x2.
I can get perfect source
classification
but not target classification.
So, this, yes.
>> So, in regards to
the problem you mentioned
on the previous slide,
the obvious solution would
be to think about doing the
bound that is not just
taking supremum over
all choices of F what really [inaudible]
all choices of F comes close to it.
>> Exactly.
>> Now, diagram might be too large
for us to like or something.
>> Yes, so that's
a very good question.
So, the bound that we wrote
down and that doesn't hold,
it doesn't hold because
we didn't force it
to hold for every fee, right?
So, it might not hold for
composition of hypothesis of fee.
That is completed right and
that's the first easy fix.
That's somewhat surprisingly missing
from a lot of the papers doing this.
The adaptation community
has been a lot
of empirical work for
the last couple years,
at least, a lot of it.
But yeah, that's a good point.
So, yes, I think it should
be long a little bit.
I think I might get to
that question, if it's okay.
So, another way to talk about this
failure cases essentially considering
predicting the effect of
a drug T and we assume
that this T has an adverse reaction
or an adverse effect
for some patients,
that could be allergic to
some component in this drug.
The point is that this indicator for
an allergic reaction that we
might know that a person
is allergic to something,
it will not be predictive of
the outcome that we see in
our observational data
set because doctors might
not treat patients that
have this property, right?
So, even if we observe
this in our data,
even if we have the indicator,
we will throw it out if we do
some variable selection
or something like that.
So, this is an easy way,
this can go wrong.
So, another problem with
existing domain
adaptation methods and
I'll soon come to what we did.
I realize I'm very short on
time but I think so anyway.
But the distances that you
choose for comparing
densities matter a lot.
So, this is kind of a stupid example,
but what we're trying
to do here is to
learn from MNIST and
generalize to MNIST,
but a smaller version of MNIST.
So, we removed some of the labels
or classes, I should say.
I'll show you a few
different lines here.
This DANN is a domain out of
serial neural networks
which is exactly
what's used to create the results
on the bench marks before.
What you can see here
is as I remove digits,
more and more classes
from my target domain,
this blue line gets worse.
But what's perhaps more interesting
is that this green line
here has only trained
on the source data.
So, actually, I think this should be,
I'm little surprised about this plot,
but essentially what
happens is that when you
remove digits from the target domain,
your density difference will
be kind of artificially large.
Even if you have all the labels or
all the classes in your source,
you have overlap completely,
you have this difference between
the densities that you will penalize
in your representation
learning algorithm.
This red line here is illustrating
what will happen if you learn
your representation based on
this domain of a serial objective,
but then you train on
some labeled target data.
So, what it says essentially we
can recover a good classifier.
So, I haven't thrown away the
information in some absolute sense.
I haven't done variable
selection here clearly,
but all hope is not
lost in that sense,
but of course, we don't
have the target labels.
Another way to look at
these results is to say
that these distance metrics,
they penalize densities and
differences in the way that we
might not want to or expect.
So, these are two example tasks
that we consider.
We have a source density which is
the blue one here at a target
density and you can see these
have overlap everywhere and we
have a source and target here.
A lot of the distance metrics
that are used considered this
an easier task in the sense that
the distances between these
densities is smaller here.
But again, here we
have shared support
everywhere and we don't there
so we expect this to be an easier
task in terms of extrapolation.
So, what we can do essentially
is what I've learned in my work is to
come up with a new
representation learning
bound that is not going to be,
we don't have a shot of solving
this always, this problem,
because for the reasons that I
showed before it's impossible,
but we've improved on
a few things I think.
One of them is that we
essentially do important
sampling when we can.
If we have overlap,
there's no reason for us to over
penalize the difference
between densities.
So, in regions where we
do have shared support,
we revert to something close
to a quarter sampling.
In the regions where we don't,
we still measure
the difference in densities
between learn representation between,
sorry, the density in the
representation space but we
might loose on the realizability
that we've talked about before.
So, what this term measures here as
essentially the difference between
the label as a function of x and
the difference or in the label as
a function of the new representation.
So, if you have
an invertible representation,
for example, this will be zero,
that eight over there.
So, that means that this
holds for any representation,
but you will have this term
that you can observe at
the end, the Eta.
So, it kind of doesn't fix in
the way that you suggested.
We need a bound that's sensitive
to learn representation,
but we are left with this problem
that it is impossible to solve,
which is to say that
there are terms in
the boundary we can observe.
Now, something for us to work out is
how does this behave when our
representation is almost invertible.
If I, for example,
something that people
have considered in practice
is to add a penalty to your
bound or to your objective,
which says that you should be
able to almost reconstruct
your data from
the learner presentation,
and then is that going
to be close to zero?
Well, that remains missing.
So, the takeaways from
this part is essentially
that domain adaptation can inspire
for it cost-effective
submission I think.
In some sense
mathematically equivalent,
but if you think about the allergy
example that I gave before,
that's something that
might hurt you more in
cause and effect estimation
because you have
this very biased way of
introducing sort of non-overlap.
A doctor probably knows about
the things that might cause adverse
effect, at least some of them.
We have the same old problems that we
did before in cost of inference,
we don't really gain
much in terms of that,
but at least we can think
about new algorithms and
new ways of solving or
estimating these effects.
I think the idea of learning
low dimensional representation
or at least having
low dimensional representations
is crucial if you want
to ensure that you have overlaps.
So, if you want to do waiting
or matching or regression,
you really want to work in the
space that's sort of minimal,
but also has the assumptions
that you need.
But, in order to actually
do this in practice,
we need to figure out what are
the right assumptions for that,
that applies to a representation
learning algorithm.
Because as I mentioned,
there's no reason unless
you make it so that
the ignorability assumption or
conveyer shift assumption holds
in your new learned space.
But, we also can't assume
that we will have overlapping
the original space because
most problems are high dimensional
enough for that not to work.
So, I unfortunately
don't have time to
talk about the last topic of today,
but it's essentially.
Again, okay.
The last part, it will
be kind of brief,
but I mentioned early on that we
have sequential problems
as well where we're
interested in figuring
out what is the value of
some policy that produces
an action given a state.
So, this is your
typical reinforcement
learning setup and
people have thought
about applying this and people
have applied this to
healthcare problems as well.
So, one of them I've
already mentioned,
which is that of sepsis
management. Yeah?
>> So, before we get into that,
can I ask one question?
>> Yeah, Go ahead.
>> The stuff that
you were describing.
>> Absolutely.
>> So, one piece of information
that you didn't lose is.
So, you said, "Okay,
for some portion of the
data let's assume that they
have overlap and I
could do a good job.
>> Yeah.
>> One of a variety of
techniques that you said.
>> Yeah.
>> Then, you said and then I
know that I'm going to
basically have to go
like out of you can
call whatever you want,
but these parts were not
identified and then I'm going to
have some loss associated with
that basically trust that.
What would you didn't
use there what I hear,
is the information about the part
where you actually do have
identification as a way of doing
a check on how bad you're doing,
for the part of the distribution
that you're not using.
So, for example, let's say that you
have the support that's like on
the unit interval
between 0.4 and 0.6,
you have good overlap and so
that that part you're dialed in,
you can imagine doing your
best shot at from 0.4 to
0.5 using this algorithm across
say like 0.5 to 0.8 or something.
In using the information
to validate how
well this is doing
within [inaudible].
So, that's the one thing I think
that you're leveraging all of
your data in all of
these identified exceptions
very well that I was surprised
that you described that.
>> Yeah. I think that's
a very good point.
Short version of that question
if I were to repeat it,
Essentially, why don't I
use the notes I have of
my fitting error in the regions
where I do actually
have overlap, is that?
>> Basically.
>> Okay. So, I think that's
a very good question
and it's something
I thought a little bit about.
Essentially this part here is
completely insensitive to how
well I'm currently doing,
which seems stupid, right?
>> [inaudible] seems
stupid, it just seem like.
>> It seems unnecessary,
it seems wasteful.
>> Yes.
>> Yes, I completely agree.
So, one way to think
about that question
is essentially if we
go back a little bit.
I'm very happy you picked up on that.
This, supremum here is,
you can think of that
as the worst-case loss,
so we're taking as supremum over
loss functions of
your data or on your data.
Though, we know that most of
these are not going to happen.
We're only going to see
the losses that are
consistent with the loss that we
already observed. That's right?
So, you could write that down.
The problem is that
you have to figure
out how do I compute this thing,
for that kind of restriction.
How do I make sure that I take
the supremum only over things
that are consistent with
the error that I already observed
and I think if you're
doing something like that,
there's a formulation of
this where you're using
essentially an adversarial loss
[inaudible] network, for example.
I think you have a better shot
at doing it there,
Then, for what we've used here,
which I didn't go into very much,
but they're essentially
kernel based distances
like the maxim immune discrepancy.
I think that restriction
is tougher than,
for example, an adversarial network.
So, I think, yeah,
that's a very interesting question.
>> I think it was the [inaudible]
paper last year that [inaudible].
>> Yeah. Oh, cool,
for we will talk about later.
I'm very happy to hear it.
>> Sorry. If your data [inaudible] is
coming through [inaudible] feels like
it should not be bad that in
depth of what [inaudible].
>> Can you repeat that?
>> The data [inaudible]
that you gave [inaudible].
>> Yeah,
I think that's fair, yeah.
So, if you have a sort of
a kernel based hypothesis
to match this discrepancy.
It might be extreme
corporate constraint,
I think that's true.
Thanks for that comment.
Yes.
So, let's see.
I think that's also
interesting for the purpose
of analyzing the domain
adaptation example further.
In the sense that in
the common net space that we
use for these classifiers,
it is likely that the labels
in the two different domains
are not that far apart or
the images from the same labels.
We're relying on
some kind of closeness.
If that wasn't true,
we probably couldn't.
First of all, we wouldn't
get those results,
but we also couldn't break
it as easily as we did.
We're relying on some kind
of closeness like that and
having then this consistency
constraint would be useful.
Okay. So, people have
thought about
reinforcement learning in
healthcare and in fact the rise
freedom papers that
apply off policy RL to
exactly this problem where
your goal is essentially to
manage a few different things.
The most, the simplest version
of the problem that people have
considered is dosing vasopressors,
which is a drug that artificially
increases the blood pressure
of the patient.
So, what happens often
is that a patient
that has sepsis or a lot
of people in the ICU in
general have breathing failure
and are put on
mechanical ventilation,
which means that they
might have to be sedated
to cope with the pain of intubation,
which means that their blood
pressure might go down and then
you have to artificially
sort of tweak that.
So, what is the right dosage
of vasopressors and
when should you take
them off because it can't have
long-lasting or long-term
adverse effects.
It's an interesting problem. Now, if
you do this or if you
solve this problem,
how should we evaluate the
policies that we learned.
Essentially, if we come up with
something using a false URL,
we will get some policy out and
we want to have to figure out
should we apply it in practice and
we have all the same problems
that we had before.
We have the overlap problem, we have
the ignorability problem,
but it's just much,
much worse now because
essentially where you could
consider this the overlap between
all of these different choices,
or if this is the policy that
you might expect in practice,
at least we want to know what
happens close to this policy.
But I know there's a lot of research
on specifically this question,
that the goal that you're
typically interested in is
this value of the policy which is
just the expected long-term reward.
I think I'll skip ahead a little bit.
But you know essentially that
this overlap problem becomes
worse the longer my horizon is,
and I've illustrated
that here just by
showing that if you were to do
important sampling in
a setting like this,
essentially what you're looking for
is patients in the data
that are treated exactly in
the way that your proposed policy
prescribes and the further
your horizon goes,
this group just get
smaller and smaller.
So, something called the effective
sample size is exactly this.
The number of people that you
were left with at the end,
even if this was
your original sample.
Recently, I was involved in
writing an opinion paper on this,
and there are a few problems
of course that you run
into that seemed to have been glossed
over in the literature
in a lot of cases.
So, this paper was mostly
a warning sign or a warning rather
for these kinds of analyses.
We know that important sampling has
very high variance because of
the important sampling problem.
It's also the case that some
treatment regimes or some policies
we cannot evaluate at all.
We also have the problem
that regression is
often biased and there's a lot of
good work on trying to
figure out how should we
interpolate between
these two different methods.
Confounding problem is
made worse in the sense
that we have now confounding
variables that are time-dependent,
and so, the choice of a medication
later might depend on the choice
that we made earlier.
A very common thing
is that you don't try
the same thing twice if it
didn't work the first time,
and we have to deal
with these things.
So, this is something that
has happened recently.
People have looked or researchers
that have published in
prestigious places have considered
various heuristic methods
of evaluating policies,
and I hope at this point in
the talk you will follow in
my explanation of why this
is not the right thing to
do, and this is an example.
Essentially, what you have
here on the y axis is
the mortality of a patient
in your dataset and on
the x-axis is how different was
the action that we
prescribed to that patient
from what was in the data.
What they see is that well,
we have this U-shape here
that says that if you're
far away from our policy,
then your mortality is higher,
and you can see why this
goes wrong hopefully.
But this is by no means
representative of any causal effect.
This difference between
these averages here.
So, I'll just say,
these have been bent in
some ways so you can take
averages of patients,
but it doesn't really
solve the problem.
This is no causal effect
because what are
the two interventions that I'm
comparing here between
these two groups?
Is there anything
that makes me believe
that the patient groups that are
up here in this dot is
comparable to this group here?
No. These are completely
different patients.
Anyone who's treated like this is
probably somewhat of an easy case.
Whereas, here you could have patients
that are very extreme cases.
For example, one reason
that you might have
a lower than expected treatment
in your data or
lower than expected dosage,
might be that the patient
is already too late.
There's nothing we can do,
and we can't tell that
from this plot at all.
Or it might be that if
you prescribe a- I'm not going
to go on, you get the picture.
So, you can get the same figure.
I didn't put the actual plot here,
but you can get the same figure
for a random policy.
You can get the same figure for
a constant policy in some cases.
So, this is purely an effect of
the the bias in your data and
not at all about
the quality of the policy.
So, this was mostly to illustrate
that this is something we
had to think a lot about.
I don't have a perfect solution
for you by any means,
but I thought that
that could be useful
to see if you haven't already.
The takeaway here is essentially
that off-policy RL is only
harder than the causal effect of
the problem that I
talked about before.
Overlap is aggravated and ignored
ability is harder to verify.
So, we have an opinion piece
online on this if you
want to read that.
I haven't done any
of this work alone,
as I'm sure you've
guessed at this point.
I've worked with
these beautiful people,
David, Rajesh, Uri and Nathan,
and this is me and thank
you for your attention.
Yes.
>> One question. Earlier,
you made this comment
that this struggle of
learning a representation
such that you get
both ignorability as well as
overlap and some sort of
trade-off between the two,
and I thought there was
at least one example
where that may not be true.
>> Okay.
>> I think about taking axis and
blowing it up to think about
all possible interactions
between the axis.
>> Okay.
>> Then it feels like
that's maybe safer
for interoperability with
whatever overlap was there before,
that will remain
that same amount of overlap.
The domestic blowing up
of the x axis [inaudible]
>> Sure. So, you're not
removing any information.
Yeah. That's fair.
So, another way to say that
is that you might have- so,
the question is if I artificially
blow up my x by
considering interaction,
I might have a better shot
at the ignorability
but at the same shot at overlap.
That is true. So, in
some sense you're talking about
model misspecification there.
If you consider any range of
hypothesis, it doesn't matter.
If I can learn
the interactions anyway,
it doesn't really change
the problem. It's the same thing.
>> Depends on your hypothesis.
>> Yeah. it does.
>> If the shape was going to be
linear, then it will matter.
>> Yeah. It does,
and I should say that
a lot of work from
the non-machining community has
exactly that problem, but
doesn't acknowledge it.
So, I think that's
a very valid point.
A reason that you might want to
do that instead of what I suggest
is that you might have
some domain knowledge
that says that some interaction
are very useful,
and then you get both a
better sense of ignorability
because you have
some prior information,
but you don't lose your overlap.
So, that happens a lot in practice,
but it's typically when
you have something like
a linear model. Okay.
>> [inaudible]
>> So, is there a connection between
the sequential treatment case and
the blessing of multiple causes?
I haven't thought about that,
I think the blessing
of multiple causes has
the same issue in the sense
that if you have more causes,
you have less overlap still.
There's a nice blog post by
a guy called Alexandre Dunmore,
who has thought a lot about
the old law question where he says,
argues essentially
that the blessing of
the multiple causes
is incompatible with
overlap in the sense
that if we keep adding
things that have some influence
on the treatment,
we were not going to have
overlap the more we add,
but we have to keep
adding things to get
the blessing of mul-
because their analysis
essentially taking the number
variables to the infinite limit.
Anything in between, I am not sure.
I haven't thought about
that problem at all but I think,
a typical source of power for
these things is where you observe
the same interventions in
different environments as opposed
to from the same density
all the time.
So, think of it as having
multiple source domains
rather than multiple treatments.
Because you are looking for
invariances essentially.
So there's some nice work on
that that I think could
be useful for that.
I don't know how exactly you
let relates to multiple cores.
>> Put the question
dimensionality, does it,
I guess, I keep adding,
so there's a question like
mathematical overlap.
I think there's a little graph
and the only thing I think
about the fact that,
probably the only
things that the only
variable that really
mattered and found
for the ones that seem to be
pretty predictable pausing
the treatment sign.
So, I guess I have
a question about like,
how much does a person
reality matter for
the space diversity the dimensionality
of the number of causes?
>> So, I think that's
an excellent question.
Essentially the question is,
does occur some
dimensional matter for
the variables that
are not confounders,
and no, you're completely right.
In fact, for a lot of clinical tasks,
what we observe is that something
like deep learning or doesn't add
that much of our linear model
because the features that we've
used are pretty well known and well
understood and they are
collected for a reason.
So something like a linear model
works pretty well,
and the reason I say that is that,
not only do we do prediction well,
but we also know more
about the sort of
course of structure typically
in those situations.
But when you have something
like an x-ray image,
it might be very difficult to reason
about what are
the pixels that matter.
So characterizing what part
of the space I need overlap
in is not so easy there,
and at the same could go for
text, for example text data,
or I don't know,
if there's an audio data causal
inference community it could be.
So, I think the problem
kind of remains.
What interests me a lot at the moment
is you don't necessarily need
the same confounders for every unit
either or every subject.
What you need essentially is,
a minimal representation to predict
your potential outcomes perfectly
and you need overlap in that space.
But again, as you've seen,
there's no way for us to
identify that from data.
You need domain knowledge for that.
I think it would be useful to
have a sort of shift in
the way we talk about it
though because this ignore
ability assumption is often just
put out there like a statement
but what we need is to somehow
incorporate the domain knowledge
for you to solve these problems.
But again, how to do
that, how do you define,
how do you write down
the assumptions for
an image classification problem that
becomes kind of difficult symptoms.
>> So, I guess, I was wondering.
So I think it's just nice like
the way I was thinking about,
so you present these bombs and
how to use them
because now instead
of just getting to
a point estimate of
this they didn't need.
This may give you
a confidence interval,
of course, well first of all,
[inaudible] for anything you
want to figure out but also,
when I was thinking there might
actually be a bigger utility is
if I were to think about
an iterative process.
So maybe I start with
operational data, I do something,
but then, maybe I can show like,
look these parts of space I have
like really terrible today.
It would be very helpful if I
could go and acquire some data.
But now, I feel like there's
something missing there
because it might be that,
like again, if I think about,
let's say just thinking
about a linear model,
then maybe there are a bunch of
directions in which I
have pretty good support,
and then some directions in which
I have pretty poor support,
but if I just sort of
orthogonal lines that sort of
directions effectively and get
some measurements, I'm done.
Right? So in some sense,
the question that's maybe missing is,
if I were to think about now and
adaptive strategies to guide
the next round of data collection,
how do I sort of use
these bounds to inform?
>> Yes, I think it's
a very good question.
So I like in some sense,
how do we use the balance
that I developed
to guide data collection?
There are some more answers to this.
One way I'm thinking about
that is essentially,
how do we characterize
overlap in general?
We need some way to
write down what are
the people that we would
like to observe if we could,
and that's in some sense
a problem on its own,
but in some sense not.
If you work only in
the correct space and
forget about the label,
you were typically,
you will have a more complex
characterizations that you might need
because you might say we
have overlap and nowhere.
But as you also say, like if we have
a very biased estimate of our label,
we might get the wrong groups anyway.
I don't have a perfect
answer to this.
I think what you
brought up there with
the linear model is
interesting because typically
what will happen right if
you have a linear model is
that the fit and
part of your space will influence
the fit somewhere else.
You're exactly right.
So having something flexible enough.
>> Thinking of all of these
to prevent the bombs,
you specialize your family
of regression.
So, now we refine the problem
in the sense that we can say,
well okay, first of all,
I don't care about functions
that, like you mentioned.
I don't care about functions and I'm
a bad models but they're just bad.
So now, limiting to the functions
that have good fail,
what are the parts of the
space that they're uncertain.
I would like to sample there
except like again because I mean,
if you're going to apply this,
you know better than I do,
if you're going to
apply this in any kind
of clinical or health care setting,
your end is going to be pretty small.
So, in many settings that I
apply in which are online,
I couldn't say right,
okay, I know roughly,
if I could for each data point,
have a sense of my answer
that I could just
decide and I will now get the point
that things will work out.
But you probably need
like 20 or 30 or 50 data
points that will give you now
the maximum coverage of
all the thousand space variations.
>> So one way to think
about that is that
covering or explaining
the region of space where I do
have overlap is sometimes harder
than the opposite because
you need a high-capacity
model to say,
you need essentially the right model
of the overlap to say,
to sort of conclude
that we're good enough,
but it's very easy to say,
it's sort of asymmetric.
If you have a very simple model
in which there is no overlap,
then you know there is no overlap,
but the reverse is not true.
>> In reverse on what you're
trying to certify, right?
So, I'm not trying to say that
I don't know the ground truth.
I'm just trying to say, look,
if I started [inaudible]
I'm going to start there.
I'm just trying to say,
If you gave me data
everywhere and I were to
fit the best function
from my class which might
be absolutely horrible,
I just want to do
as good a job as that.
>> Yes, well.
>> Then, I shouldn't
need to worry about
the high capacity parts, right?
>> Yes, in the sense
that your horrible model
might be too horrible to
adjust for the compounding,
so you might have
buyers in that sense.
When it comes to the overlap,
it's slightly different.
If you forget about the label,
then I agree with you.
It's enough to have
a crappy model as long as you
can give me some information
on where to look,
but it will not give you
a certificate for it that
you've looked hard enough.
So, it's kind of asymmetrically.
It will tell you, you
don't have overlap
but it won't tell you,
you have overlap.
If you have to [inaudible] .
>> You have a word with respect
to that family of models.
>> Oh, okay, if you can.
Yes, okay. That's right.
>> I define everything with
respect by this class.
>> So if you have some information,
or some idea that you're
the truth is in that family
or close to in any way,
then yes, that's completely right.
>> Okay.
>>Yes. Thank you so
much. It's a lot of fun.